las negociaciones para flexibilizar el
protocolo Irlanda del Norte van por buen
camino Aunque queda trabajo por delante
al menos esa sensación expresaron los
líderes de los cinco partidos más
importantes de la provincia británica
luego su reunión con el Primer Ministro
Richi sunak a las afueras de belfast
creo que se ha logrado un progreso muy
muy significativo y creo que un acuerdo
es absolutamente posible y necesario
Espero que veamos una conclusión rápida
y exitosa de los asuntos y que el núcleo
del protocolo sea absolutamente
protegido eso es esencial
claramente Habrá más discusiones entre
el Reino Unido y la Unión Europea Pero
creo que es seguro decir que se han
logrado avances en una variedad de áreas
Pero hay todavía algunas áreas en las
que se requiere más trabajo
en Bruselas el ministro de asuntos
exteriores británicos James cleberley se
reunió con el vicepresidente de
relaciones interinstitucionales de la
Unión Europea marus quien también
resaltó aspectos positivos del encuentro
compromiso constructivo buenos progresos
el objetivo compartido es claro
soluciones conjuntas respondiendo a las
preocupaciones cotidianas de la gente de
Irlanda del Norte el trabajo duro
continua
el protocolo Irlanda del Norte un
acuerdo logrado entre Londres y Bruselas
para no formar una frontera física entre
belfas y la República de Irlanda ha
entorpecido el aspecto comercial de la
provincia por controles burocráticos
inclusive para productos presentes de
Reino Unido un aspecto que el club
comunitario se mostró dispuesto a
reparar en contrapartida Bruselas no
pretende discutir el rol del tribunal de
justicia de la Unión Europea en belfast
pese acusaciones de quebrantar la
soberanía británica